es ahora o nunca cientos de partidarios
del grupo de la campaña ambiental
extinción rebelión protestaron una vez
más en londres exigen acciones concretas
para evitar los estragos del cambio
climático la principal amenaza para las
futuras generaciones
estoy aquí luchando por mi nieto mi
hijastro y su encantadora esposa y por
las futuras generaciones porque esto no
va a ser nada agradable va a ser muy
difícil la gente tendrá que ser muy
resistente es impactante que hayamos
hecho esto en tan poco tiempo dallas del
planeta y que hayamos eliminado algunas
especies lo siento si sueno deprimida
pero estoy deprimido
el mundo ya vive las repercusiones del
calentamiento del planeta países del
mediterráneo y eeuu han sufrido
incendios forestales severos china india
y alemania se vieron afectadas por
inundaciones y en groenlandia llovió por
primera vez en la historia y
elevar la temperatura de un grado por
debajo del punto de congelación a un
grado por encima del punto de
congelación
si estás en el océano ártico es una
diferencia entre patinar sobre hielo y
nadar y ahí es donde vemos que estos
pequeños cambios pueden tener efectos
mayores
el más reciente informe de naciones
unidas habla de un código rojo para la
humanidad e indica que américa latina
será una de las regiones más afectadas
por el fenómeno se espera un aumento del
nivel del mar y sequías huracanes e
incendios más frecuentes además la
unicef afirmó que alrededor de mil
millones de niños están en riesgo por
los efectos del cambio climático todo
empeorará si no se logra detener la
emisión de gases de efecto invernadero